so feminism is and has always been a
hate movement
and it started in 1848 in seneca falls
new york the suffrages had 200 men and
100 women in the 1800s to 1920s they
were seen as terrorists planning
assassinate assassinations it is
a supremacism the majority of women did
not actually want the right to vote
because it came with being drafted um
that is true the thing is i believe i
agree with the last part not so much the
beginning part so much how can you
disagree with like
like the way that they they viewed that
movement back then yeah i think it's
been turned into a hate group but at the
beginning i mean you could say the same
about like my life king of malcolm x can
you the beginning was that quote-unquote
hate group in certain people's eyes but
like i think so you think if they're
planning assassinations
that doesn't that doesn't that doesn't
put them yeah i mean it puts him as uh
as
a
and it was the majority men led the
suffrages had 200 men yeah they're a
threat right and it was a terrorist
organization but i wouldn't say they
were hate group they become a hate group
they have become a hater
but i don't think they started
originally to be a hate group so you
just like don't believe them no no i
believe it and and i agree with you with
the with with how it's being said but i
don't agree with
i think it's just the word hate group i
don't think that's the right word to use
i think why
because it's a hate group now okay and
it's and it's ramped up with third wave
so if it's a hate group now after it's
ramped up right but it was it was it
basically wanted to give women more
power without the responsibility yeah
yeah that's okay so at the cost of men
in a way because we wanted the power of
being able to vote but we didn't want to
be drafted
the majority of people throughout
history didn't get the right to vote
because you had to own land yeah
how is it
i'm trying to understand like how is it
how would you consider it a hate group
now but not back then and they're
consider their
uh what did they say about assassination
they said if they were alive today they
would have been seen the way that
um people see antifa i'm 100 yeah
but i don't i also don't it wouldn't be
weird because
it's weird because um
i think the way my mind works is they
they there was at least
at the beginning
a fight now the fight is just the fight
the fight the fight that they're having
now is just the fights who have a fight
because there's nothing that you don't
have there's nothing that you don't you
can't do there's no
thing that you can't do but the reason i
don't call them a hate group back then
is because at least maybe i'm speaking
of hindsight the same way those girls
were speaking at least you could argue
oh they were fighting for
something that was tangible that
assassinations assassinations is crazy
no matter what you did but then we have
to ask the questions like yo does that
make america so in general
are we gonna start we when we start
going down that rabbit hole it's like
mate
does anyone know why we're in war with
syria
right but that's a whole different
conversation
but that i think the political
standpoint is why i wouldn't necessarily
call them a hate group first what if i
said
i don't believe in abortion so what if i
said we should assassinate that guy
because i have a good cause
again
that doesn't hurt again
cause ian duary
legitimate assassination
the assassinations i'm not back in in
any way no i know i know but
yeah but it is yeah
i think i think my biggest issue is just
the word because i think they're a hate
group now right i think they've become a
hate group
but in my head to justify me thinking
they've become a hate group
you kind of have to think that they've
at least come from a place of making
some sort of fight for something that
somewhat makes sense to some people okay
so so again so the pro-life thing that
would make sense to some people yeah
if i if i was leading a group of people
and i said let's let's kill let's let i
want to say this but let's assassinate a
certain political figure
in the name of this group
you think it i wouldn't be a hate group
of course so what if so what about
something
i'm not even going to say the group but
what about a certain group that
huh no
no a group back in the day they had an
idea that
they
they were superior than
a certain group and so they thought in
their mind hey let's try to
assassinate them
doesn't start with okay
so but then
but then it's one of those things where
it's like but
the people on the other side could
literally say the black panthers were
the same thing
but the black panthers did not really it
did it obviously it was in self-defense
but history is written by the winners
[Laughter]
but they weren't planning assassination
yeah some
they were handful they were planning
assassins not planning assassinations
but it's planet planning violence in
some respect they were planning violence
oh i didn't know that i think you're
talking about violence in defense yeah
of course but that's not really planning
violence bro standing outside your house
yeah of course
that's what i'm saying
different angles and different views
this is this is what my point was i
don't know if i would use the word my
whole thing was fixated on the word
hatred right it wasn't i agreed with
everything else you said it's just the
word hate group i think that's
a level nine when they were a level
seven they're planning assassination
yeah that's a that's not if that's not a
nine i don't know what a nine is what
group who wants to make a change isn't
planning an assassination
i could think of the pro-life movement i
could think of one right there i mean
but you wouldn't call i wouldn't call
the pro-life movement aggressive
i know yeah so it's not a hate group
they're aggressive and angry but it's
good and they do it at the like the the
feminism did it at the expense of men
because again they were taking away the
responsibility of what came with voting
and so
that's what i'm saying so i would it's a
hate group if they're planning
assassinations and getting rights at the
expense of men
i don't know
i think hate group is slightly too
strong
it sounds so feminine
no because it's just the words you're
using
yes are they still planning
assassinations they're not planning
assassinations but i would call them i
would call them a hate group because
they they hate men yeah and it's at the
expense of men so you know the
assassinations have just added to it
yeah it's like and they do character
assassinations
they ruin lives god they might not be
planning to do it with a gun but [ __ ]
they ruined johnny depp's life and a lot
of men i think i'm very fixated on the
language side rather than
like more than i probably should be
yeah i don't know they're assassinating
mentally mentally financially now then
physically weird
but i do agree with the fact that one
the
the pill and all that and and the vote
was to not go into the draft which
allows because you asked a lot of
females all right cool would you go into
the draft now the answer is no
i would give up my right to vote
between getting drafted and vote i would
hey
easy
the thing is take away if you ask a lot
of guys they say the same but we just
kind of have to do it
because because we don't have a choice
yeah it goes back to men are seen as
expendable in society
if there's if there's a boat going down
who gets off first the women and the
children children
if there's a fire you guys go fast yeah
if king kong comes to break down the
whole scene you have to escort
and it goes so going off of feminism so
feminism encouraged women basically to
sleep around
right which we went over that has
negative consequences to chase their
career over a family and prioritize that
first
which um single childless women over the
age of 45 are the least happy
and on top of that
they wanted
abortion as a fail-safe so they pushed
for abortion rights
and iber abortion is the ultimate form
of hypergamy
so it's basically saying i that guy is
not good enough to be a father
because if a girl's obsessed with a guy
she's carrying his kid he can't convince
her to abort it
yeah
how many how many of those uh like uh
what's it mind-blown
how many of those cases where the guy
has to pay
i can't even think of the word child
support how many other child support
cases do you think is from a from a
child that was born because the mom
wanted and that didn't
i mean
they'll steal condoms to get it
like if they want to carry a dude's kit
like a girl will jump
over hoops to carry it she wants to
carry it and she's already pregnant
she's holding it yeah
that's what happened to it
did you hear about that thing with drake
it was a while back yeah yeah where you
put hot sauce in the condom yeah because
she was trying to she was trying to keep
it and she put me people say well he
shouldn't be sleeping with women like
that and it's like
how someone said it on the last podcast
and i was sitting in the car and i was
like how can you how do you say that i'm
like obviously it's drake and he's not
going to be like well hey are you going
to try to take my sperm out the condom
and insert it in you after this
like drake's going to do what he he
wants to do because he's in that
position to do that yeah and it's like
nobody looked at the female like why are
you doing that like why is that um like
like not screaming like that's crazy
that you actually went in the bathroom
and was like i'm going to trap drake
because he's drake yeah but the fact
that she can actually go to like
and try to press charges on him yeah
that is the audacity for you to think
through that at what exactly what you
just explained that she did and then for
her to even have the audacity to even go
and press charges on him like he's done
something like you did it to yourself
you guys did you guys hear about the
aziz ansari story
a while back
oh
the comedian who basically canceled
because he had a bad date with a girl
yeah like she he was pressuring her it
was like pressure basically
he was pressuring her but pressuring
isn't assault
[Music]
get me wrong i it's annoying
it is irritated i'm sure every girl in
this room has been like been in a
situation where i just won't leave it
alone but we're not gonna put it on the
men because like you put yourself in
that situation you can leave um they
gave each other oral sex like at least
three times each
and she
and then she made an anonymous like twit
log oh that she gave her i thought i
thought he was like pushing her to do it
and they both did it through each other
they were drinking wine that just makes
it worse they went they were they were
in from my recollection they were in a
she took on a date
um he kind of rushed through the dinner
because obviously i think his mind was
somewhere else and it was part of the
whole forcing thing right oh russian so
he was rushing through the bottle of
wine he wanted to bring the bottle of
wine home they get they get home they
start drinking
she says that she's somewhat
uncomfortable well according to her
story um
but then they start uh kissing and she
gets more slightly more comfortable with
it to the point where they give you
trouble or sex like three or four times
each right so she gives it to him he
gives it to her
and then uh
like
a few weeks months passed and then she
made like a twitter twitter
post basically saying oh this guy or as
usual he should be canceled because he
forced me into giving him oral sex three
times
i was like uh first of all
no one
forced you to do it
i think he just you just it's social
pressure sure but you don't have to give
in to that so you don't you understand
it man
like it's weird
but like we live in a we live in a
society where a girl can do it like
imagine if a guy did that um
she pressured like basically she
pressured me or she pressured me into
sex
yeah they wouldn't even because i know
everything yeah they wouldn't i know a
lot i know i'm not sure let me let me
not say it with chess but i know there's
a lot of guys maybe both of you guys in
this room who've had stories where you
were pressured by her she put on you big
man it wasn't you want her
he's laughing because he knows the thing
is he's laughing because he knows right
a lot of guys have gone through that
situation where low-key
it wasn't me that
[Laughter]
insinuated this low-key obviously i'm
gonna go with it because i'm a man and
you know being being yeah but loki
you pushed it on me but
if i was to then the next day i'd be
like oh my i didn't actually want to
have sex
[Laughter]
it's weird though like it's so it's so
weird because once you see this you
can't unsee it that's the thing
and it's it's every it's literally
everywhere in society
and it's crazy too because
we're incentivized for bad behavior
so if we get for a single mom like we
get child support yeah
for 18 years so so
we're paid to be single mothers we're
well fair
like how
how insane is that if we if we sleep
with the with the rapper and we get a
kid off of him we had a bag for 18 years
yeah
what did what did kevin samuel say about
um
future in his 10 wife or was it kevin
simon
it was like everyone gets on future for
having 10 kids but no one gets on all
yeah
the nine goes after the first one right
because there's there's always an excuse
for women like if a man's sleeping
around we hear that all the time jess oh
he shouldn't be sleeping around he
should wrap it da da up but when a girl
gets pregnant if i say okay that's your
own fault
um you put yourself in that situation um
there's a million firms of birth control
you could have tried you also could have
an abortion worst case so if you're a
single mom i don't feel bad for you
because you chose that and if if you
picked the wrong guy i i don't feel bad
for you either because you need to learn
to pick better that's your own five
empathy for you but like you made your
bed but that's crazy
but
when we i say when ever i show empathy
to men the first reaction
is oh well he shouldn't sleep around